your live chat
thank you very much indeed
right ladies and gents good evening
welcome to this Northwest area planning
committee on the 16th of August
my name is councilor Mark Durham and I
am chairman of this committee members we
are streaming this meeting live as well
as recording
and by being present in the meeting
you're giving your consent to being
recorded and during each item please put
your hand up to indicate if you wish to
speak and I will then invite you at the
appropriate time please note the YouTube
live stream sound reporting recording is
dependent on the correct use of the
microphone therefore can I ask when
invited to speak you remember to turn on
your microphone and turn it off when
finished please reference a page or
paragraph number when referring to the
agenda papers and keep your
contributions as clear and concise as
possible please avoid repeating the same
comments that have already been made
item two apologies for absence uh have
we any apologies I don't think we have I
think we've got a full house
excellent well done um
out of three minutes uh it's recommended
that minutes of the meeting held on
uh the sixth oh no that's today
um
the minutes of the meeting held on the
21st of June 2023
uh approved as an accurate record
members
thank you very much indeed
um
item four Declarations of interest to
disclose the existence and nature of any
disclosable pecuniary interests other
registerable interests and
non-registerable interests relating to
the items of business on the agenda this
evening having a regard to paragraph 9
and paragraph and appendix B of the code
of conduct for members and members you
are reminded that you are also required
to disclose any such interest as soon as
they you become aware should the need
arise through the meeting
okay that's done and dusted the official
bits item five
our first report
uh it's going to be
so item five uh land at Poplar Grove
Farm great totem and this was a call in
by former councilor Keys who is taking
us through this one I believe so Lisa
Greenwood okay and she's uh she's in The
Ether good evening Mr Greenwood hello
would you like to take us through this
item then please yep okay
the application site is located on the
western side of Broadway Street Arena on
the southern side of Poplar Grove Chase
and it's outside that we Define second
boundary
the site represents an undeveloped
passive land to later grass about the
thick thick vegetation along the
majority of boundaries
to the north of the site is a row of
linear residential development the West
is popular very far a great University
building to the South is the designated
strategic site of hay Bridge Garden
suburb which is a hybrid scheme for the
development of up to 1 to 138 dwellings
time commission is sought to the
erection of nine dwellings the dwellings
will provide a mix of two three
ounce bedrooms blocked one to eight will
be of two stories and plot nine will
provide for a bungalow
as you can see for the next three slides
plots one to eight opposed to measure
between 0.7 and 9.4 meters in height and
the ridge height of the Bungalow would
be 5.7 meters
a landscape buffer is proposed and this
is the view from the street scene
turning to the principle of development
as stated the site is outside the
settlement boundary
the great sort of neighborhood plan
states that new development can focused
within the settlement boundaries of
North and South totter policy S8 of the
ldp steers new development towards the
existing urban area however this policy
does allow for development outside of
rural areas where the intrinsic
character and beauty of the countryside
is not adversely impacted upon and
provided that is for a specified
purpose that satisfies other policies in
the local plan
these purposes do not apply in this
instance and a scheme does not propose
any significant benefits over over and
above policy compliant requirements I.E
such affordable housing to weigh in the
planning balance and might be taken into
account to mitigate the harm caused by
the conflict with Planet policy
whilst it's acknowledge that the site is
accessible you can see the access to the
site here and how it links to the
suburbs below
concern is raised to the design of the
scheme and its impact on the countryside
the site provides an area of Meadowland
the meadow and Associated boundary
treatments provide a visual break
between the residential development to
the North and the development to the
south at the gate hay Bridge Golf
the site is also well related to the
nearby Heritage asset
the site is considered to be constrained
in planning to
and as such any development would need
to be sympathetically designed to ensure
that the harm is not caused to the
Heritage asset but also to the character
and appearance of the area as a whole
whilst yeah whilst the applicant has
sought to retain an area of Maryland to
the north to reduce this impact the
developers proposed would not rank the
highway
instead a new internal access is
proposed
and this would not appear as a
continuation sorry and this would appear
as a continuation to the Garden suburb
by virtue of the layout which provides a
new Access Road excessive pipes New
Roads parking areas of paraphernalia the
development would appear as legally
prominent and would urbanize the signs
the applicant has failed to provide for
affordable housing despite meeting the
quality threshold to do so and has not
submitted a unilateral undertaking and
paid the relevant checking and
monitoring fees to mitigate against the
recreational harm caused by the
development
the addition The Proposal would also
result in a low level of part to the
holistic building and it is not
considered that any benefits would
overcome this
turning lastly to the matter of access
and Highway Safety and new access is
proposed of Broad Street Green the
proposal has been reviewed by the
highway Authority who note that whilst
every application is assessed on its own
Merit in this instance a planning
application has also been submitted to
the Council on a site to the southeast
for nine dwellings at Gary's annexes
this is online to the rear 53 and 55
Broad Street greens in this particular
instance the two proposals would have a
wider impact on each other and the local
Highway Network as such The Authority
has requested that the outcome shipment
submit to stage one Road Safety Orders
the first should assess the proposal on
its own merits and the second to take
into account the similar proposal on the
opposite side of the carriage rate at
this juncture the audits have not been
received an objection is therefore
reigned by the highway Authority as
insufficient information has been
submitted to demonstrate that the
proposal would be an acceptable in terms
of Highway Safety and efficiency in
relation to the new access
but if we stated this application is
recommended for refusal
thank you thank you very much I
understand we have
um one speaker
um who's an objector is that correct
that's correct oh okay
um is it Mrs Beals is she online or is
she
okay
uh
so do we have Miss Beals is she I think
she's online
she's on teams can you hear us
can you hear us
yes I can oh good that's great thank you
very much well um you will have two
minutes
um I'm presuming you can't see our timer
so um we will indicate verbally when we
have um
20 odd seconds left if that's okay
that's fine so and we'll start the clock
when you start speaking
I'm going to interrupt you Mrs it's
I don't know if you remember Norman
Collier but you were sounding very much
like Norman Collier and we were only
getting bits of each word so
um
do you want to try again
I'll try again is that any better yes
that's better
okay so um most of my original reception
I did put down a writing so I literally
just asked that since that detriment in
place there's been two other
applications in place and I know it just
mentioned them by the highways agency
but I live along that stretch pretty
much opposite where the new entrance
would be and I sit and work in my front
room window and I would say about four
or five times a day that sits me around
about what's been put in place it was
frequently and overtaken apart right now
like literally can't Supply past my
Bright House 50 60 miles an hour I've
got nine-year-old son that I now won't
let go outside the fronts because of how
many cars go past and if there's enough
entrance there but it literally it's an
accident waiting to happen
it also work very very closely with West
crane Park and I know for a fact that
they are really struggling to sell the
houses there so I do get you know people
need new housing they need to put in
place but I think the needs in this area
that site has proved a loan that
actually there is not as much beneath as
what we would think and we've just been
proposed plus another side across rate
of it and now there's another kind of
application for sites on the road as
well is there really a need for this
number of houses in this area
does that conclude your statement uh yes
thank you very much indeed I don't think
we have any more public speakers do we
no so I'll go to Members First and
counselor Thompson's indicated first
oh thank you chairman um I propose we
accept the officer's recommendation if I
can get that second difference
right okay so we have a proposal to
accept the officer's recommendation to
refuse
um I'm going to councilor Morgan then
councilor white yeah I think it was Jim
it's just really a matter of
clarification uh I realize it's probably
a typo it would be interesting just okay
exactly what it means what it meant to
say that is a clause 3.3.3
uh the proposal has also been found to
cause less than less substantial harm
for the greatest Farmhouse could the
officer perhaps explain what that should
have said or
uh thank you chairman yeah it's actually
not a typo
um it's taken from the words of the
um of the nppf
they use terms like list and substantial
harm and that sort of thing yeah so it's
actually not a typo
it just it just reads to the degree of
um harm to a Heritage asset
there is substantial and less than
substantial harm listen to substantial
harm doesn't necessarily mean that
um
there you know there is insignificant
harm it's just harm just certain lessons
less than significant
so so just to be clear so it's not it's
not causing it's not likely to cause
substantial harm to the heritage is that
what you're saying well substantial harm
would be significant damage to the
fabric of the of the listed building it
wouldn't result in that but it's still a
level of harm it's just less than
substantial
right it's just the nature of the word
and that they use and um it's fairly in
the last few years new nomenclature in
the in the nppf and uh
yeah
perhaps I'll put that straight councilor
white thank you chairman uh thank you Mr
chairman um yeah mine is really um could
we go back to the map where you've got
all of the approved applications where
they were in green
right so the one to the the bottom of
the page is that the garden suburb or is
the top right one okay so yeah
right okay so so for me with policy S8
the fact that it's actually next door to
a strategic site that one doesn't bother
me this other site on the other side of
the road what stage is that at
um because I'm I'm just surprised that
they're going to they've been asked to
do a road survey to include the
application on the list of the road and
how many houses is that one
um
about the very topic server is isn't
normal practice they have to practice
because normally each site is assessed
on its individual parents but in this
particular instance because this
application literally came in the other
one not my one or R1 this one came in
after 30 days the highway Authority it
was the same officer that received both
applications and called us and said you
know we're going to ask both applicants
to produce the road safety audit because
actually this will impact you know if
both come forward
um we need to actually consider not just
the individual sites but the site it
relates to the other site as well now I
spoke to the officer who is managing the
application and it's the ninth relics
the garage annexes
um Sarah and that application at the
moment is in process and she's receiving
consultation responses
I don't it hasn't been called into
committee as far as I believe it yeah if
I might come back it's just for a matter
of clarity so but are they both for nine
houses
how many houses is the other application
so I'm just yes yes both nine right okay
and because it just seems a little bit
unfair that because this one's come
first one for me one of the major
reasons for refusal is the road because
it is highways raising issue I've not
personally not got a problem with the
application itself because of its
location adjacent to the sites but I do
have a bit of an issue with the road
thing obviously if highways there's a
problem we can't go against that but it
just seems a bit unfair that how do I go
with the applicants told they had to do
these surveys was it a long time ago or
could they have got them done before
they've had sufficient time and um
in actuality this application is
unacceptable for other reasons so we've
provided them with time to
give us the road survey however this
application would have been recommended
for a few years or for other reasons the
only reason it's before the committee is
because councilor Keys had it is
otherwise it would have been refused
because it is contrary to local plan
policies yeah I've got some other points
as well but I mean for me personally I
I've not got a problem with the other
um Parts like officers do but that's
that's a member's gift to interpret the
mppf differently
um but um that for me I mean Rams could
have been done by con condition
um and I say it was just this thing with
the road do we know if the other
applicants did their survey just to
clarify actually we can't actually
condition rounds rounds okay
fair enough
okay and if you might indulge with my
last question has the other applicant
done the road survey and if they did
what were the outcomes of their surveys
do we know
um so no I I don't know how far off they
are with their own survey but it would
be it would be on a case-by-case basis
we wouldn't be able to use their
information for this application
right I think that's certainly right
okay question counselor siddle
uh yeah just want to question the
accuracy of that map on the left hand
side because the garden village does not
go all the way up to where it's been
projected this is that this is taken
from our
where their sights are in relation to
each other that
uh that unfortunately our map is before
that one up slightly higher than it
should be so so that so that so the
actual uh Garden Village is on the other
side of the roundabout much further down
the road and when the Beltway
application was put through the houses
next to the relief road because of the
effect that they were having on the
grade list grade one greater listed Farm
had to be designed differently and that
was taken into consideration these
particular properties would have a huge
impact on that farm would have a huge
impact on Broad Street Green Broad
Street Green is already a dangerous road
you know that access just after the
roundabout you know
yeah highways I'm pleased that they've
objected to it and they've racist thing
because it would create even more Danger
on on Broad Street Green
um so yeah we have to go with the
officer's recommendation
okay I don't see any other members
indicating so we have a proposal to
accept the officer's recommendation of
refusal proposed by councilor Thompson
seconded by councilor Morgan uh so would
you like to indicate those in favor of
that proposal
and that is unanimous so that is refused
thank you members
uh next item
okay you're right apologies let's scroll
scroll scroll
uh agenda item six this is land west of
Crown Road gold Norton
um and that it will be found on page
from page 37 and this was another member
call in by
uh former councilor Fleming also with
the officer's recommendation to refuse
who is taking us through this one
again
okay
have you was there a members update I
believe for this one yeah there was a
members update yes that's correct
yeah fantastic
this is an outline application it all
matters apart from the means of access
being reserved for future consideration
The Proposal is up for up to 14
dwellings with vehicle circulation
parking hard and soft landscaping and
Associated development
here we have the location plan the site
is accessed from Crown Road to the South
along an unlaid track the site lies
outside the settlement boundary but it
joins it on its southern boundary at the
southwestern corner
Corner the site includes Crown Lodge
which will be demolished to facilitate
the development as well as grazing land
and a paddock Crown Loach is a
residential dwelling there's a public
right-of-way that runs along the north
of the site and one to the eastern
boundary
this is the illustrative layout although
an access although access is a reserve
matter access is included and shows the
internal estate Road and therefore the
layout of the site would largely be
dictated by the positioning of the
internal Road layout although the new
development now includes the area of
land occupied by Crown Lodge the
development is still considered to be
contrary to the prevailing pattern of
development
the building height plan shows two-story
dwellings along the western edge of the
sites with single story properties on
the Eastern Edge or centrally within the
site
this is the junction Arrangement plan
and shows the access to the site onto
Crown Road and visibility slave displays
an objection has been raised by the
local Highway Authority because it has
not been demonstrated that their
appropriate visibility displays at the
junction of Crown Road with Lexington
Road there's also been no details
submitted to identifying appropriate
measures to improve walking and cycling
from the development along Crown Road
and unmade and unlit private road there
is also conflict between pedestrian
cyclists and vehicles that will be
intensified by the development and the
number of dwellings proposed resulting
in the deterioration of the public
right-of-way and to the detriment of
Highway Safety
but this is the tree survey plan and
this shows the trees to be removed down
here in red in the southwest corner of
the site
slide 7 shows the previously dismissed
scheme this shows the location plan and
the indicative layout for four Bungalows
at the site and this was dismissed on
appeal due to the harm caused to the
character and appearance of the
countryside
the previous scheme did not include
Crown Lodge the inspector considering
the appeal noted the following key
points Crown Lodge marks the aim to the
perceived line of development from the
village the openness and Rural quality
of this land are positive aspects of the
character and appearance of the area the
dwellings further along Crown Road are
spatially and Visually separated from
the village and appear established
dwellings developers in this location we
completely changed the character of the
land giving a more urbanized appearance
and the marked transition into the
countryside
the previous scheme should be noted was
for four dwellings
as such the level of urbanization was
lesser than the application before us
yet the inspectors still consider the
harm to the character and appearance of
the area to be unacceptable
now the photos show the application site
from Crown Road and demonstrates the
openness of Crown Road on both sides of
the road particularly in the aerial
image
the development is not considered in
flow development due to the distance
between the application site and the
development to the north
it's instead seen as an unacceptable
sprawl of development to the north
beyond the existing built form to the
South
this shows the existing dwelling at
crowd Lodge as well as Crown Road and
laboring properties
these faces are taken from the public
right-of-way looking north and west the
development particularly the two-story
dwellings along the west Edge would have
demonstrable impacts on the public
right-of-way
these photographs taken from Crown Road
looking along the road from the public
Raceway entrance as well as at the
public right-of-way itself
side shift at Northern end of Crown Road
now dwellings here are surrounded um oh
sorry do I need the northern edge of
Crown Road and surrounding areas showing
it's Detachment from the southern end of
the road any new development at this
location since the determination of the
previous application has been absorbed
within the context of the existing
development therefore the relationship
between the application site and the
development to the north remains largely
as it did previously
there are more photographs of the
Northern end of Crown Road and the more
sporadic developments besides the age of
the northern part of the built form
these photographs are taken from Cherry
Blossom Lane and the surrounding areas
and Cherry Blossom Lane is located to
the west of the site
to conclude based on the assessment
undertaking in the officer's report the
proposed residential development would
result in an unacceptable urbanizing
effect into what is currently considered
an area constituting the countryside and
an unresolved harm to the natural
environment in terms of the impacts of
biodiversity and ecological assets the
ecological concerns relate to a lack of
certainty over the impacts on Great
Crested needs in in addition the
proposed development would not provide
suitable visibility visibility displays
or appropriate measures to improve and
promote cycling and walking from the
site which would result in an
unacceptable degree of Hazard to all
Road users and proud to provide suitable
access to the detriment of Highway
Safety
proposal would also intensify the
conflict and interference between
pedestrians and vehicles using the
public footpath which would lead to a
deterioration of the public right-of-way
on the basis of the assessment within
this report it's concluded that the harm
caused by the development would outweigh
the positive elements of approving this
Commission thank you chair
thank you very much indeed I think we
have one public speaker which is the
applicant I think it's Mr Spurgeon is
that correct so would you like to take a
seat with a microphone
I think you know the routine anyway
um and as you've heard you will have two
minutes from when you start speaking
please turn your microphone on
there you are thank you
right thank you chair
um right there well there are a number
of areas of concern they're effectively
only one real matter of substance as we
see it um that can't be overcome by
conditional completed legal agreement
related to the principle of development
and it's evident that the recommendation
for refusal of this application is
essentially due to the location of the
site outside but adjoining the
settlement boundary of cold Norton and
assessing the impact officer suggests
that the proposal would represent
unwarranted development in the
countryside and refer to it as
unacceptable sprawl we would strongly
contest these descriptions and findings
and suggest that the scheme is more
accurate describe as infilling between
existing areas of development
particularly to the South and West and
as a modest extension to the Village
it's notable that the council has
actually assessed the site is suitable
for new housing suggesting it could
provide land for around 20 homes and one
has acknowledged that this assessment is
provided in an evidence-based document
and not in planning policy it does
clearly contradict the position set out
in the officer's report
the impact of development on the rural
character of there is ultimately what
has led officers to conclude that
permission should be refused however
while the site may be considered as part
of the countryside it is something of a
stretch to describe this as a rural
location when it's comprised of an
existing house and garden with a close
relationship to the settlement boundary
and the existing residential areas
within the village
in this case the site is not considered
sensitive in landscape or visual terms
it's not accessible to the public and
does not have any particular ecological
value or value as Countryside in its own
right as the evidence-based document
recognizes is exactly the kind of
unconstrained site that needs to be
developed if sufficient housing is to be
delivered across the district
so overall it represents a suitable site
for housing as well as a deliverable and
well-considered scheme which should be
considered favorably given it as of a
scale and nature which is entirely
appropriate in this location
given that we provide six out of a total
of 14 dwellings as affordable homes is
not surprising the scheme as a few in is
enthusiastically supported by the
council's Strategic Housing Services
Department
I was therefore strongly urge members to
give their back into this scheme and
look to support the provision of much
needed new homes
suppose you I think we get the gist
thank you very much thank you very much
um
members
um I'm going to cancel a wife first
because it's on your patch we do of
course have a recommendation from
highways yeah which is a
actually for once I'm going to agree
with officers again that this I agree
with recommendation and then and I
suggest it should be refused but before
we vote on it I'd actually like to raise
some points I mean I'm normally the um
the queen of uh supporting
um generally speaking and development in
my ward but this is just a step too far
you know I I think the fact that they
had the four houses uh lost at appeal
dismissed appeal and now they want to
adopt 14 just doesn't really make a lot
of sense and I also think this was a
very dangerous precedent because this is
on a road that doesn't actually go
anywhere it's a dead end
um and I just think it's the wrong
development in the wrong place so for
that reason I for once actually support
the recommendation of refusal I think
there's that some proposal to accept the
officer's recommendation seconded by
councilor Morley councilor Thompson you
had indicated that's pretty much what I
was going to say thank you chairman
enough and
if I hear some more I might change my
mind but as as things stand I'm happy to
see the members have any contrary views
or other questions I would like to ask
the officers
nobody is indicating so we have a
proposal to accept the officer's
recommendation to refuse this
uh for the reasons already provided uh
proposed by councilor Miss White
seconded by councilor Morley please
indicate those in favor
thank you very much that's unanimous
that is refused
thank you members moving on to
that's counselor Stevens I'm sorry I
thought
thank you chair just before we move on
to the next item can I ask a question
through you of the officers I understand
that where members have made call-ins
and are no longer members that we still
have to have these applications coming
to council and I just I really want to
explore that and see if is that
definitely true or could these if there
are any other applications outstanding
that will still come forward of this
nature could
could we all be emailed to see if
anybody else supports them being called
in because I can see us just be we could
be here in a year's time looking at
applications that none of us have any
interest in councilor Stevens I would
have thought we were probably getting to
the end of it
I mean because under normal
circumstances the officer will contact
the member that called it in
with their View and requests whether
they they wish to
retain the calling obviously that wasn't
possible in the last two cases um
councilor
Thompson
I think standing right that absolutely
is the case
um I think this requires a minor change
perhaps not that minor to the
Constitution I'm looking across the
leader here who's nodding
um and I'm a member of performance
governance and audit and I shall make
sure okay this goes there so we can deal
with it thank you very much so yeah I I
would doubt there'll be many more
councilor Morgan
uh well just to say that um the um the
whole business of planning and
enforcements being looked at by the
office of oversight and security
committee so as a chairman add this that
particular point to the list yeah okay I
think it's just one of the anomalies of
having a post-election situation okay so
we now have um items seven
uh which is land adjacent to Honeywood
Farm Honeypot Lane pearly that's a call
in from councilor Miss White
councilor Tom sorry chairman but could
you allow a two-minute adjournment so
that Thompson can have a comfort break
because
I have a little problem I'm more than
happy to uh to to oblige Council Miss
Thompson so if I just go obviously I
missed the beginning no so that will
five minutes suffice cancel attention
thank you very much I'll adjourn for
five minutes
oh
[Music]
that's the wrong way
that's it and Luke
thank you very much indeed welcome back
members and anybody who happens to be
watching this live it's not very much
doubt but um so our agenda item seven is
to be found on from page 67 this is land
adjacent to Honeywood Farm Honeypot Lane
pearly and this is a call in by
councilor Miss White and Mr doe you're
taking us through this one
thank you chairman
this is the last item on the agenda it
relates to land at the rear of um
Honeywood Farm I'm just uh going to
bring up a map
putting the site in context the um the
site is over to the right hand side
uh the hatched red area the solid red
area is the Victor access and then at
the front of the site is
um honey pot Lane
to the north there at the top is Stow
Road and then bottom to the left is the
sort of set the center of the settlement
of stone Maries
honey pot Lane goes through to the South
to lower Burnham road so that's the
general setting to the site
moving on to the next presentation here
is the the site location plan and
um as mentioned before the the site is
to the rear of Honey Wood Farm there's
some commercial
units immediately to the West
to the um to the north to the north west
is the only residential property
anywhere near this
um this site Fowler's Farm it's got some
ponds to the rear of it in a wooded area
to the south of the site is a brighter
way on a former Railway embankment but
the railway embankment is treed there's
there's trees all the way along the
brighter way
otherwise the site is surrounded by a
golf course to the South is a golf
course and the top right hand corner
there you can see is is a golf course as
well
moving on to the block plan
the proposal was for six of this unit
six office pods they're arranged in a
U-shaped
Arrangement as has been indicated there
um two office pods and a shared kitchen
to each arm as it were
um that's shown in a bit more detail in
the floor plan
um a WC just off the kitchen each each
office unit each pod small but would
have its own kitchen would share an
entrance into
quite an attractive
um Courtyard feature with flower beds a
canopy stroke gazebo at the front
um indeed the Gazebo is shown at the
front there this is the part of the site
to the rear there's adequate car parking
provision this is the view to the north
um the units are quite attractively
finished off they have a Timber finish
this is the victory access to the site
um cheb and uh thank you that that
concludes my report
thank you very much Mr doe I don't think
we have any public speakers for this
um just look at that as you say
yesterday they're very small and I know
that although they've got two units as a
hospitality
company's gonna have six staff it's
three staff in each it's pretty tight
isn't it but
well
I mean that's their issue I guess but I
mean I'm guessing that's
within limits I'm
letting chair we consulted environmental
health no no yeah no it's just an
observation staff would be there at the
same time yes I'm sure I'm sure
um
so I've got cancer Miss White then
councilor Morgan
uh thank you Mr chairman um I will say
that I do know the applicant because
he's a member of the stomare's parish
council
um but but that's all um and I have to
say I was actually I called this in
because I I thought this would be down
for refusal um especially in the light
that it's got three kitchens
um but I'm I'm really pleased it's done
for approval because we need this
business sites this this land here has
always been used for business of one
sort or another and it's a bit of a
hodgepodge and um I'm really pleased
that it's down for approval um and I'd
like to propose that we accept the
officer's recommendation
seconded
proposal by councilor white secondly by
councilor Morgan Council Morgan you
indicated uh yeah it's just released
more point of information I know that
the application of proposal to section
73a is that because it's a retrospective
application
well in the word chair yes is the answer
um it's up and running with no apparent
problem
okay
slightly regrettable its retrospective
but counselor and Morley yeah just as
smooth is is there
I don't have a problem with it but is
with some of the other other
applications we've looked at there's
often a concern
because of kitchens and things like that
it could be used for living and things
like that is there I would very much if
you in doubt you're gonna live in no
we've got moves living in a box I think
there's a good song actually it is a
good song yeah there's there's a
condition that the commercial members
used as members commercial units
um condition
two
um the the E-class which is yeah
yeah I I think it's duly protected
councilor Thompson
thank you um
application was
in a change of classes of use and did
something get
moved around so they needed a different
type class of use or am I barking up
completely the wrong tree thank you
well chair there's there's various
things going on at Honeywood Farm
um recently
um
at land further to the South West
there's various things going on at the
farm the um uh the owner seems quite
enterprising
uh quite how this
came to light
um the details Escape me I'm afraid but
it's it's it's being regularized now
the one thing I would add is that when
we look at the planning history under
Section six
um there was a previous
um
section 73a application uh for the
change of use of agricultural buildings
to use class B8
storage and distribution now
um
there would not have been the permitted
uh change of use within the use classes
between B8 and and and and and this sort
of use
um so hence hence the application I mean
obviously it just seemed that over time
in the applicant seeing what's an
attractive operation they would have
gone for the change of use and this is
just just to regularize it and just to
remind although I know sometimes um it's
it is sort of said that one should not
carry out development without getting
planning permission but lawfully it's
it's not illegal yeah it's only if we
then find that it's unacceptable and we
serve an enforcement notice
thank you okay well
um okay any other members wish to to
comment if failing that I have a
proposal to accept the officer's
recommendation I think that was
councilor white and seconded by
councilor Morgan was it yes
please indicate members if you support
that
and I'll go along with that that again
is unanimous thank you very much members
that is the last item on the agenda so
members thank you for your contributions
for this meeting
oh Council Stevens yes I'm sorry you
have to be quicker apologies oh it was
very quick but you're reading something
um I don't understand really why we've
just heard this last one either
um in the Constitution it says where a
member's request is the only reason for
an application being referred to the
area committee the director of Service
delivery will notify the member of his
recommendation on the application
following which the member May withdraw
his or her request so through you check
can I ask if that conversation took
place and what the outcome of it was
please very good point
well Sarah
yet yes there was an email I think it
was this one and I said I was happy with
the officer's recommendation I mean
unless it came in too late I don't know
but I there was there was one that I had
an email for last week and um it said
was I happy with the officer
recommendation of approval I came back
and said yes
so unless it was a different application
I don't know I'm sorry did you say last
week
that would have been a bit late yeah but
whenever it was I I sent an email back a
day or two later when I picked it up
might have been the same day I think
it's better
you make a very good point and I think
perhaps members might note if they call
in
it would be beneficial for everybody's
sake
um just to keep a check of where that
particular application is
giving the officer plenty of time to
come back and so you can decide whether
you wish to call in to remain
um but it was a good point well made
thank you councilor Stevens yeah yeah I
mean I'll just add that um normally it's
the case that um most callings that I've
seen
um members who asked did you say they
call in the application subject to have
Insight of the officer's report that
tends to give me an indication you know
you kind of have this little sense of
how things might be and the normally
officers would act on that I mean we
don't really want to produce a committee
report if we don't have to if we feel
that our recommendation is like to be in
sync with with members of you so not
sure what happened here I'd have to sort
of look into the file but we'll we'll
just look into it I know that you know a
couple of callings I've made I've made
the officers Like Hell by I'm trying to
find out what's happening to it and we
all know which one that is so members
thank you very much for your
contributions we will now close the
meeting at
8 15 as the meeting is now closed please
do not enter in any further discussions
and leave the meeting promptly thank you
very much members